So far you've created promises and
chained the some work off them.
You did so in the last quiz by
creating a get function and
then using .then to do something
with the data that you retrieved.
You also included catches to ensure
that no error goes unhandled.
With the promise API,
.then also return promises.
So if you can .then off
of an initial promise,
you can .then off of .thens
because they are also promises.
Developers commonly use the term
thenable to describe promise in .thens.
Any method or
object that returns a .then is thenable.
Anything thenable can become a part
of a chain of asynchronous work.
Promises are thenable as are .thens and
.catches.
In fact, other libraries
include thenable objects.
See the instructor notes for
more information.
When creating a chain of asynchronous
work, each subsequent link in the chain
receives either the fulfilled
value of the previous promise or
the return value of
the previous .thens function.
In this way,
you can pass information collected from
one asynchronous method to the next.
Being able to chain thenables is
an incredibly powerful technique for
simplifying complex sequences
of asynchronous work.
You'll be practicing a few chaining
strategies in the next lesson.
So this is the end of the first lesson.
You have already added a powerful
new tool to your toolbox, and
you are just getting started.
At the beginning of the next
lesson you'll be creating a chain
of .thens to put thumbnails
on the Exoplanet Explorer.
See you then.